bonjour à tous alors nouvelle vidéo
cette fois ci un peu différente de ce
que j'avais l'habitude de faire sur
check point com met donc ces vidéos
d'actualité et c'est pour féliciter marc
andré à morzine donc bien de réaliser sa
première nombre de maître international
donc l âge de 11 ans donc ça c'est
remarquable
d'après ce que j'ai pu lire dans les
commentaires de léo sur facebook c'est
que ça doit être le genre français le
plus jeune âge à marthe et 92 mg quoi
donc même avant mais tiennent ou mvm
donc même si l'époque un peu différente
ça reste vraiment notable est bon voilà
pas ça me fait plusieurs pour lui parce
que ce gentil garçon et puis je connais
pas mal ses parents qui sont ils sont
cool aussi
et voilà donc bah moi forcément j'avais
remarqué depuis longtemps marquant dream
team est battu il ya déjà un an et demi
tournoi de porticcio en corse et et
voilà donc la c
il avait ces derniers temps pas vraiment
gagné deux points a plutôt perdu là
était assez sous classe et je crois que
les deux lunes 28 et et la voilà donc et
il a bien réagi fait donc une norme de
métro autour de vendeuvre là en début
d'année vendeur c'est vers nancy et donc
il a fait plutôt un bon tournoi j'ai
noté ce qu'il a fait je vous dirai plus
rien de ces partis dans le tournoi donc
qu'il a joué contre jérémy de vallée
c'est georges connaît mais j'ai regardé
donc ce genre de chartres qui est pas
loin de mille trois cents lots quoi donc
donc bon joueur
- donc on a été battus benoit tu as des
as dis donc ça c'est un joueur part à 21
ans si m enfin cette région 2290 doit-on
vacances bien et ce jour je connais je
vais je compris la première fois en 98 à
l'accession qu'il ya bien longtemps
après la fin d'une ronde 2 contre alexis
tél je connais bien la région lyonnaise
j'ai été champion de france junior qu'il
ya deux ans quoi après rentrée labatut
de emi anatolie obi vanhoof d'ukraine
donc 23 74 donc très très gros début de
tournoi et je pense que j'analyse race
est parti
ce sera un petit article aussi sur le
sur le site de check point com pour
trouver les articles
et elle sera en format vous pourrez
télécharger un pgm quoi par écrit après
24 il a fait une course fis alors je
veux pas m'attaquer apprend sous le nom
allait j'essaye rakotomaharo des
conflits le nom j'attribue jet ski c'est
pas simple mais j'ai l'habitude mais ok
donc moi je l'appelle toujours fines
donc vrai qu'on connaît pas mal bien de
faire nul après il a perdu contre
alexandre pigeât donc je dois jeunes
joueurs français 2317 yen cette partie
beaucoup jouent spies même temps je vais
pas entrer une partie où il doit faire
on se doute qu'il a battu laurent paoli
22 1342 donc
pierre laurent pas au lit donc ce genre
je crois vers avignon quoi qui travaille
pas mal
j'avais vu à riga je te cadet je pense
et donc c'est bien c'est de battre un
joueur pareil il perd la rende huit
contre le maître chinois libye qui
quasiment 2524 notre 1,8 et et victoire
à dernier avant je pense qu'il donne la
norme contre l'udc a dit nick holland
tonio base joueurs de marché pas pour
quelques bijoux mais je conseille de la
région de grenoble quoi donc 23 88 et
voilà retour mois et donc je vous
propose qu'on jette un oeil à sa partie
donc ils allaient blanc c'est la ronde
si c'est donc marc andré vient de perdre
et donc ses parties de 400 adversaires
les joueurs c'est très bien qu'il y ait
trois et des six donc fi lidar convoi
plus ici perd souvent évidemment on a
beaucoup plus l'habitude de voir
qualifier 6 et à haut niveau bien sûr
etc et renault qui nous a souvent joué
des des petrov mais des six donc c'est
la défense qui leader c'est pas mal là
juste puisqu'on habitude de voir quand
les normes la fille de delors deux coups
avec des 6 au premier coup je suis là
mais ok si on prend des quatre qu'elle
les prend des 4 et cavalli m6 ok donc et
c3 flo7 n'ont pour l'instant c'est la
variante disons moderne nos stands de
coûts de la filière est ici marc andry
joue un petit coup de le patron qu'il
faut le qui est très bien en fait rien à
dire
poussé katsav pourrait sembler plus
logique à première vue mais je pense
qu'en fait c'est moins bien que shaw
deux parce que parfois énormes thème
soit de faire un des cinq pour casser le
centre soit de faire car elle y prend le
4 est sûre qu'elle allait prendre faire
des 5
donc ça ferait une fourchette et il sera
récupèrerait sa récupérer le matériel et
sa égaliserait la situation au centre un
exemple de vente comme ça alors je dis
pas que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
absolument ne sais juste pour illustrer
ses parents plaidera que les blancs rock
noir jouent ces 6
donc ça c'est très fréquent pour créer
une petite barrière ici donc contre les
cases et éventuellement menacer bay 5-1
vont prendre de l'espace son propre
compte faceb--k chc ce cavalier cagnes
espion et au passage volant quand on
devient un casse des cinq et on peut
peut-être pousser des cinq parfois les
oncles et blanc face à quatre pour
bloquer et là par exemple ça ça
marcherait pas mal prise prises des 5
bon ça équilibre justin ça égalise on va
dire pour les noirs après fou des trois
pions prendre quatre il faut prendre
quatre là mais donc c'est pour ça que le
fond ces quatre ans et pas forcément
fantastique ici donc faux de très bien
et à noter que donc deux autre manière
de jouer qui
ils sont reconnus par être avec moi tant
bien si c'est faux f4 avec l'idée de
faire dam des deux grands rock ou alors
aussi un autre coup développement
tranquille c g 3g trois bombes à pouvoir
toucher de me fait simplement les
rockets mais de g2 le fout pas mal ça va
défendre quatre et il va aussi empêché
les noirs de réaliser la percée des 5
donc c'est pas mal pourquoi c'est bien
de défendre quatre simplement parce que
normalement c'est là dessus qu'il est
noir cherche à faire leur contre je non
prolongé que ces drogués mettre une tour
en huit ans déjà il y aurait la tour
plus le cavalier qui comptera regard des
4,5 et libye 8 normalement il va venir
ce localisant c5 via 17 ou via 1,6 à
voir est en tout cas la france et cinq
et on arrivera toujours à le défendre ou
quatre mais du coup ça va un peu
interfère avec nos pièces quoi donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai trois aussi pas
bête donc ok mais il faut de jouer très
bien petit rac petit rock et il a un
coût sûrement douteux les noms ont joué
à cinq je pense n'est pas besoin
j'imagine que l'idée de deux vallées
avec les noirs c'était de sécuriser la
casse ces 5 km le cavalier mais à vrai
dire c'est pas trois ça va conserver son
avantage au plan les experts en fait
dans cette variante avec les noirs voire
du tournoi mamediarov au même mur tu as
je vais saaq et noir ou etienne bacrot
ses tours 8 donc comme on disait déjà
essayé de mettre la pression là-dessus
et donc ça semble logique et les lance
joseph quatre fois de suite
voilà comment s'attaquer le pion bon
défend et il a un clessé 6,5 alors en
général cette structure les mauvaises
pour les noirs savons que son secret un
pays arriéré et on lâche le contrôle de
la caisse des 5
mais là ça juste leur donner un peu de
jeu parce que le cas il faut bouger
dijon qui a eu lieu deux je pense le
case logic éventuellement pour rebondir
là bas disons qu'elle et ses 6
on voit que c'est pas simple de se
développer avant trois coups comme floue
et 3 il y aurait calé g4 qui arrivera
donc peut-être les blancs un coup comme
baies 3par trouvait dos pas mal même en
plaidant se développe au regard qu'ont
fait flouer 2 et la victoire des huit
idb 5 et bon ok ça joue en fait c'est
une position compliquée je sais pas
vraiment qui est mieux que je préfère
les blancs mais c'est pas si simple
parce que six cavaliers des qui bouge
hop le quesnoy revenir en d4 d5 arrive
dynamiquement les noirs sont pas mal
quoi il se serait plus comme ça qu'il
faudrait jouer côté vous achetez pour le
petit côté théorique
alors toi qui leur arrive à 5 et la
marque contre ils jouent très bien avec
les blancs des coûts très logique mais
très bien fait il fait f4 ok tu t'ouvres
tours 8
fo est roi et place d'une pièce pour les
fuites donc là était noirci le plan
d'armes à feu ou trois coups de
développement super six et un coût que
j'aime bien la part de marc andré ces
fouilles de alors c'est un peu
prophylactique parce que le fou ici en
l'air ça peut se laisser des embrouilles
abbas deux des cinq à base de québec des
cinq des choses comme ça donc pas mal et
deuxième truc section des fringues dam
des deux pareils on entre le plus à
caser 4 et donc on s'expose à du fou g4
ou du cavaly g4 donc je fais de très
bien parce que donc on enlève le fou de
cette case ont fait pas d'amener de en
lâchant la case et puis peut-être que le
foot peut avoir un avenir par là bas un
jour qui sait pas alors qu'ali 17 je
vais parler noir développement alors
peut-être peut-être que les rames
assistaient
un peu plus précis pourquoi pas
s'appliquer à 17,20 fondée en profite à
jouer dam des deux est le truc c'est
qu'il ya plus de kg 4 vu que on a bloqué
le flou et donc si on avait joué tout
être corrélé à 6 le tchèque 17 les
blancs peut-être pas trop jeune des deux
a le droit comme tout revient donc ça
reste un peu mieux pour les blancs bien
évidemment mais bon tout reste à faire
cahill et cette dame des deux très bien
dames c'est cette hockey et tour à 20
donc les blancs c'est très bien
centralisation total des pièces et les
blancs dont peut-être essayer de faire
soit ou comme e5 un moment peut-être
qu'on a lâché fou par là bas où
commencer une attaque g4 g5 etc etc et
et l'a donc un peu sous pression les
noirs font font une faute faute tactique
il joue le couple les six bons qu'à
première vue je peux comprendre c'est
pour développer le foot soit en bessette
soi insiste d'ailleurs
et voilà donc la très haut blanc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
joueriez quoi vous marc-andré bas à
trouver et il a joué quatre ans et six
donc très bien pourquoi parce que si
dame prend ont fait eux 5 et mon créneau
filâtre donc on va gagner une qualité et
si et noir de bloquer avec des cinq de
toute façon ça ne change rien parce
qu'il y avait les prend et puis on ouvre
quand même la diagonale on note de
prendre part échec
donc ça serait la cata
alors en fait je sais pas c'est à dire
sa gaffe et pas vu ça où s'il a cru qu
il faut s deux fois ci c'est s'en sortir
mais quoi qu'il en soit il y aura quand
même de grosses compensation pour la
qualité mais en fait même pas sûr que la
marque ont des contenus très bien et je
vous le meilleur coût possible
il joue que cinq donc ouvrir le four
attaque et 6 et déjà les noirs pression
compliqué alors ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'ils ont pris en f1 non ils ont pris
en 5 par an là entre gérard décès me
dire tiens bon est-ce qu'on peut pas et
ses gaffes de prendre un peu de matériel
en prenant en f1 est en fait la réponse
est plutôt non parce que les blancs
prendra ici par exemple est donc déjà on
a récupéré une question à tourner on
sait qu'une qualité et on attaque en f1
et aux menaces éventuellement qui a eu
lieu cet avenir mais voilà pendant que
les noirs sauvent leur pièce disons
qu'on prenne la faut prendre parce que
bon ben si il reprend je pense qu'on
peut faire un truc comme comme dam des
quatre échecs et double attaque donc
vous prend et curieux de cette option
donc le point de départ
ceux qui vont perdre leurs qualités
qu'ils allaient davance ils ont droit
faible ça va pas trop simplement plus
donc c'est un peu ça bon que 5 il a pris
il a pris hier france 5 bat prend pareil
vous réitère un peu les mêmes menaces il
ya eu vous prend f1 et il ya eu plein de
points 26 hockey et là dessus donc les
noirs je fous ces 4
on peut se demander si peut-être c'était
pas mieux de prendre la barre dame prend
et 200 avec le fou disons 1 à 6 puisque
bon ok déjà cahier set ça marchera
toujours à peu près à quoi mais il ya
encore mieux pour les blancs c'est en
fait c'est de prendre ici problème
pourquoi c'est que s'il vous prend en
fait on défend plus à cazaux cette
affaire kallio cet échec et on va taper
la tour
donc on aura une pièce de plus au au
total au final ce qui a payé tout donc
on prend le 7 bat faut faire pour faire
pour apprendre et en plus maintenant on
voit que même le roi va être faible en
dessous des 4 et si le roi s'en va on
ramène une seconde pièce à l'attack on
menace cabello 7-6 6 dames français et
six en fait on parade tu parles je suis
comme didier roustan j'étais remuer
pendant les streams les vidéos bref au
grand écran bon on a un homme de plus
donc aider 500 m des six et comme bomba
très simplement on peut faire ça qui a
lieu cette prise prises et comprendre la
tour et là on a encore mieux on un petit
coussin pas ici dans la position s'il
faut g7 pourquoi parce que si roy prend
bond majeur à une fourchette ici
sirois 8 qu'est ce qu'on ferait bon au
pire on prend un vilain mais
l'impression que voilà un peu peut-être
même trouvé mieux
ça c'est joli ça canet-66 donc échec et
sur dano seaska logique ils seront 21
pim pam pas malgré un tableau que les
trois pièces mineurs avec qui si qui
l'encerclent rock band coordination des
pièces bon moi tout ça c'est juste
complètement illustratif mais c'est
contré les frênes que les noirs peuvent
avoir dans balancent leurs positions
alors ouais alors après puis on prend un
f6 les dents fait tousser 4 ayew prend
il ya eu ce loupé ranger cette ue qui a
valu au sat il ya eu tout reprendre bon
alors évidemment on pouvait peut-être
bouger droit et fuite vous prend la
victoire prend 1,8 c'était toujours
pareil un plus en plus pour les blancs
initiative donc donc très bien à
tourcoing le stade pour prendre le set
et l'a donc pas de nouveaux problèmes
arrivent cerclées d'or ont déjà un pour
moi et ils sont pas sortis de l'auberge
pour autant puisqu'il va ville est
attaquée
la tour est hyper actif un septième
rangée c'est toujours un problème ça et
autour des 8 et marc-andré continuer cas
très bon coup qui est fou des cinq ans
fait pourquoi très bien parce que
attaqué vii et comment le défendre
problème c'est que si fou prend des cinq
ont fait dame prend et on attaque à la
fois f7 et on garde un oeil sur le
cavalier et je sais pas enfin il ya rien
à faire c'est à dire que le seul coût
qui serait peut-être défensif ces
tourets fuite mais dont on disait on
perd la pièce ouais donc vous prenez ça
ne va pas avec les mains de qui tente de
s'accrocher il fait b5 tant bien que mal
bon on sent que ça doit craquer a bien
sûr alors il vous prend 6 4
l'idée en fait c'est que si on prend par
contre il veut rejouer d'amd 5 donc la
même vente qu on avait juste avant donc
il faut compter trois heures d'attenté
mais elle a bien joué d'alger cinq
échecs le chou et harmonieux angers7
et pour preuve cet abandon pourquoi me
semble qu'il ya matin parle simplement
parce que si on menace dame prend ici
et puis barré d'affaires disons sur sur
2,5
des gens pourraient prendre là tous
rendez vite mais il ya même juste du
tout ça pour trancher cette donc il fait
un double échec quoi et donc à matha
venir donc les yeux abandon en fait
après tourcoing f7 et donc une victoire
assez rapide dans cette partie de marc
andré
ah ça impressionnant parce que bon dans
son jeu il a joué de manière logique et
bien quoi et dès qu'une petite technique
il l'a vu après la plus relâchée sa
proie
donc voila encore bravo à lui
et puis et puis j'espère que ça
continuera bien pour lui je sais pas
s'il a prévu d'autres tournois à
l'avenir poursuivre à 100 tout cas avec
avec un tas attention quoi voilà bah
écoutez vous souhaite une bonne journée
à tous en prendra donc ensuite avec la
vidéo plus classique sur les joueurs du
du passé mais je conçois que sympa de
voilà enfin dans la section actualités
et donc sensei sur les joueurs français
marc andrieu quoi même si les corses
voilà à les chercheurs